Can you give us an idea of
a typical application, and
in particular, how big it is,
how long it takes to develop?
>> Sure.
So there are two or three,
as I said, different kinds of
applications that we tend to develop.
I think one, that is a good
representative is the Forecast Manager.
So a forecast manager,
is an application that will forecast
customer demand for
products at various locations,
various stores, of a retailer
based on a historical analysis of
how those products have sold at those
stores over the past two to three years.
It takes into account special events
like promotions that are enforce and
it's actually a pretty
complicated set of calculations.
It involves some regression analysis and
it's pretty involved.
So, we generally,
when we have a customer,
what we'll do is, every week or
maybe even every day,
we will generate new forecasts for
them in a big nightly batch.
Nightly or weekly batch.
And we'll calculate the next
52 weeks of forecast for
all their products at all their stores.
After which, most retailers have
a group of employees who go through and
review those forecasts.
And if they find things don't
look like they have imagined,
because it's forecasting, it's not,
you know, it's not an exact science.
They'll want to get in and do some
tweaking, make some adjustments to them,
maybe they think that some estimates
of increased demand are too high or
too low, and they'll actually
want to make some changes.
So forecast manager
application's responsible for
generating all these forecasts
allowing forecasters,
the employees at a retail organization
to go through and drill up and
drill down, and
try to understand these forecasts, and
also to allow them to make
changes to the forecast.
Tweak them, what if them, et cetera.
>> And they can use they forecasts
to predict sales and do inventory?
>> Correct.
>> Sorts of things.
It's central to they're planning.
>> It's very similar to their plan,
yeah.
It's typically hooked up with
replenishment systems as well.
So once they approve the forecasts
that we've suggested for them, they'll
then send those forecasts down to a
replenishment system which will actually
make orders and cause goods to be put
on trucks or on ships or whatever.
>> And I imagine with all this
data that there are kind of
heavyweight calculations,
functional requirements that
the forecast manager has to satisfy.
>> That's correct, that's correct.
And what's interesting about it, and
what I found particular in working in
the retail domain was surprising,
let's put it that way.
There are, every different client has
slightly different business requirements
that make it very difficult to
design a completely generic product.
So there's always a bit of client
specific business rules that you need to
take into account and configuration.
It's not like a shrink
wrap product at all.
So, it really is when you want
to sell this to a new clien,
even if it's a product very similar
to one you've released before.
You have to do a fair amount of, you
have to staff it up with a development
team, and you know, do or extend
an existing requirements analysis.
And do some custom protection.
>> And so when you say product
before you were talking about
software as a service,
the products are really services.
>> That's correct, Yes.
>> Okay,and what I'm hearing is that
you don't want to have to do
a separate forecaster for
every one of your customers, but
there are individual pieces.
Each customer has their individual
needs, and so you need some solution for
them specifically, but you can't
have a general one for everybody.
>> That's correct, that's correct.
That's one of the core parts of
the problem that makes it hard.
>> Okay, now how about on
the non-functional side?
What sort of interesting non
functional characteristics do these
applications have?
>> Yeah, you can break them
into a couple of categories.
One is, you asked earlier about
how we get data and we load it, so
that implies that there's a batch
operation that has to load all this
data that come in, into our database.
The batches tend to have pretty
tight timing requirements.
So, for example, when we do
forecasting at the end of a week for
next week's orders,
we typically get the revised sales data
that we use in predicting, we'll get
that sometime late on a Friday evening.
We may get any number of other
kind of data from the customer,
as well,
that we need to use in prediction.
We'll have to have the forecast all
generated and ready for inspection and
modification for the forecasters when
they arrive by 8 AM Monday morning.
So there's a batch window and that
batch window is a very hard deadline.
If we can't do all the work within
that deadline, we have a service level
agreement with customers because
we sell this as a service, and
if we don't meet our batch window, then
we're in violation of that agreement,
that has financial implications,
et cetera.
So batch requirements are big.
We also have a nightly batch which
has a much tighter window and
doesn't consume as much data.
>> So in the weekend situation, is that
enough time for you to deal with things?
How much of that weekend is
consumed with actually computing?
>> So that's a good question.
It depends largely by client.
We, for our bigger clients, we have
one that I think their app is now,
it's over 11 terabytes of data that
we have to maintain and let them use.
And what we do is,
we actually partition the database.
Over many different nodes,
many different nodes on the cloud, so
that we can meet this batch window.
And what we find when
we're scaling these up is,
we have to do some experiments to
decide how big, how fat can we make one
database in order to meet our
batch window to load all,
not just to do the calculations,
just to load the data to begin with,
because it takes a while to
load 6 terabytes of data.
So we have to, we have to scale
ourselves and partition it so that we
can load all the data, perform all the
calculations within the batch window.
And there's always a trade off between,
the more that you can make,
you can decrease your batch time,
if you throw more machines at it, but
then that increases your cost,
our company's cost which we have to eat.
So we're always trying to
optimize that sweet spot.
>> So what I'm hearing is that
you're making use of a large number
of fairly heavyweight server nodes
on the cloud that are cranking
pretty much full time over the weekend-
>> That's correct.
>> To make sure you hit your
deadline for Monday morning.
>> That's correct, that's correct.
And one of things that's interesting
about deploying as a service,
has everything to do with that problem.
So traditionally, when a retailer
would want a forecasting application,
that retailer would have to buy and
maintain all the machinery he or
she might need in order to generate
those forecasts even though you're
only going to do it every week,
every weekend sorry.
So, what typically happens with the
forecasting application is, it's a of
heavyweight work on the weekend, but
then during the week, not so much.
And so our solution scales, so that
we actually scale up over the weekend
in order to do all this data loading and
calculation.
But then we scale back down to a smaller
footprint after all those calculations.
>> So
you're taking advantage of the fact that
you can get elastic computing resources
>> Elasticity, exactly.
>> Off the cloud and
only pay for what you need.
>> Precisely.
>> So, I interrupted you before when you
were talking about the nonfunctional
requirements, what else is there?
>> So
batch requirements is the one category.
The other category
are interactive requirements.
So, users are going to,
as I mentioned when,
after we generate all these forecasts
you're going to want to go through and
inspect them and analyze them, and drill
up, and drill down, and make analyses,
and maybe even modifications.
So, that's a large set of data
that they need to operate over.
And anytime you have users doing
interactive queries over large
data sets,
you have the potential that queries and
operations could take a very long time.
So in addition to our batch window,
we also have to design and
partition accordingly so
that queries will be,
user operations will be
performed in acceptable times.
>> And I'm assuming that you've kind
of mentioned that reliability is
really important.
>> Hm-mm
>> Okay this,
you have to get the thing done.
>> Yeah.
>> How about accuracy of these
computations, how do you deal with that?
>> Yeah, so
usually through a separate process, so
Logicblocks has a dedicated data
science team that works with
big retailers who are very familiar with
their own data to do accuracy analysis.
And we tend to do this by
running our forecasting offline,
and comparing on old data, and then
comparing it with actual sales data, so
there s some metrics
we used called mean.
Mean percent error which
are used to decide whether
your forecasts
are sufficiently accurate.
If they're within a certain
percent error of the actual sales.
And so, we tend to do that offline,
and then if there are any changes to
the algorithms, the science algorithms,
we roll those into the service so
that it'll be available next week
when we do the next analysis.
>> So some real significant,
non functional requirements,
in order to make all this work in a
fashion that can satisfy your customers.
>> Right.
>> Okay,
how about the architecture itself,
let's say of the Forecast Manager,
what makes this particular application
architecturally interesting?
>> Okay, so
I think from an architecture standpoint,
what makes this architecture most
interesting is the distribution aspect.
The services oriented
design of the whole thing.
And how each of the distributed
nodes talk to one another.
So I have a diagram we
can take a quick look at.
This is a multi tier diagram.
I'm not showing the top tier,
because the top tier is
basically a web browser, right?
So all of our clients, they're top
tier, presentation tier,
would be there web browser.
They're going to be running HTML 5,
JavaScript applications,
running in their browsers that are
periodically going to make service calls
to a uniform location on the cloud.
Those requests, those http service
requests will all go through this
front end node that I'm
showing here in this diagram.
We consider that the middle tier,
all right?
So the front end of our
application is a middle tier
that has a couple of databases running
on it, which I'm showing there.
One of them is largely
the one called UI0.
It is hosting services
which do things like either
directly answer queries or
proxy them down to
other nodes that actually contain
a slice of the real data.
And so
that data tier level that I'm showing
in the diagram, actually has multiple.
I'm abstracting it by just showing 2,
but there could be up to 50, or 60, or
100 of these things depending
on the size of the data.
Each one of them is the same in terms
of what code they're running, but
they have a different partition of
the data that they're responsible for,
and each one of them is running
a web server that's hosting
services that answer queries,
all right, or do updates.
So typically in this architecture,
you don't see this much when you're
running the app from your browser,
but you'll click on a link to go drill
down into, you know, the results
of some query that will issue a request
that goes to this front end node,
which may then delegate to one or more
of those data tier nodes to gather some
data, perform some updates, put it back
together and then get your response.
And all this has to work very quickly.
>> So, as far as architectural style,
would you say this is
a three tier architecture?
>> Yes, yes.
>> And, complicated by the fact that
you've partitioned your data across
many, may networks.
>> Correct, correct.